[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here coming at you
from uh the brand new soft long sleeve
available at shop.com along with the
rest of our lineup that's available
shipping and time for the holidays so
definitely make sure you get in on that
link below the like button but i am
holding in my hands right now a sony
smartphone
but not just any phone i'm holding the
phone with the most impressive hardware
camera setup of any smartphone out right
now
but
there is a catch so this is the sony
xperia pro i so we've been having some
conversations around the studio about
how some companies treat their
smartphone lines basically based on how
much money it makes that company so like
apple and samsung spend a ton of energy
on their phones because a ton of their
money comes from how good their phones
are
but microsoft for example makes so much
of their money in enterprise that a
consumer phone doesn't really move the
needle for them whether it succeeds or
not
and same argument could be made for
google who's mostly an ads company so
the pixel doesn't really have to be a
world-class phone for google to be okay
so then there's sony
and sony makes a lot of stuff they make
the playstation 5 they make the sony
alpha cameras they run movie studios
they've got a lot going on making them
money and they also happen to make
smartphones too sure but the smartphones
are not one of the high priority things
so it shouldn't surprise anyone that a
full year after we found ourselves
wondering why people don't buy sony's
super interesting super niche
smartphones they're back at it again
with another one with another ridiculous
set of quirks and features this phone
has a 4k 120 hertz oled display i'll say
that again a 4k
120 hertz oled display and in that
unconventionally tall 21 by 9 aspect
ratio that makes the six and a half inch
screen look narrow but also still be
easy to hold it's got all the buttons on
the side including a dedicated camera
shutter button with the half press for
auto focus and a second press for
snapping a shot plus a second custom
button alongside it that launches their
custom made built-in video pro app on
this phone it's still got the underrated
tool-less sim card tray which is
back-to-back with the rare micro sd card
slot for adding up to a terabyte of
extra storage to the phone
there is a high quality headphone jack
up top too naturally and this phone has
an eyelet at the corner for a wrist
strap because of course it does and also
in classic sony fashion this phone is
called the sony xperia pro i
but so they had the xperia 1
and then they had the xperia 1
mark 3 with eyes representing the 3 and
so now this is the pro i it's like
they're trying to make it as confusing
as possible but the cherry on top of
everything is this phone is 1
799
and launches in a month
classic sony but like i said at the
beginning this this is what makes the
phone the pro i has an incredible
hardware system that's what i want to
talk about in this video um you would
think with this incredible hardware it
takes the best photos and videos
we'll get to that in a second but yeah
this
is really impressive so sony xperia i
has a ridiculous
massive one inch sensor for that main
camera now it's also flanked by a 12
megapixel ultrawide camera up top and
then there's also a depth sensor and a
2x telephoto camera below it but let's
talk about that main camera smartphone
camera sensors have been getting larger
and larger lately reaping all the
benefits all the light gathering all the
shallow depth of field as a result
this phone has the largest we've ever
seen a full one-inch diagonal so for
some perspective the iphone just moved
from a one over two point five five inch
sensor last year to a one over one point
nine inch bigger sensor this year the
pixel six and six pro with their
headline making new sensor it's one over
1.3 inches which is matching the samsung
galaxy s21 ultra and xiaomi's mi 11
ultra with one of the largest camera
bumps of all time has a one over one
point one inch sensor this sony xperia i
the i stands for imaging turns out is
all about this massive new barrier being
broken of a full one-inch diagonal
sensor that is the largest sensor ever
fit into the back of a phone now some of
you who are in the photography world
might recognize that's the same size
sensor that's in their world-class
point-and-shoot cameras the rx100 mark 7
has a one-inch sensor
and i know that's true because this is
the sensor from the rx100 mark 7. those
two devices have this same one-inch cmos
sensor inside for taking photos and
videos that is
that is pretty incredible for a
smartphone it kind of feels like a
camera first that happens to have a
phone attached to it so it's already
really interesting for that but wait
there's more so most smartphone lens
elements inside are typically plastic a
lot of people didn't know that i
actually learned that pretty recently
up until the main outside lens which is
glass all plastic on the inside but not
the sony the sony is using aspherical
glass lens elements inside it's very
expensive to do that but for the sake of
optical quality that's what they wanted
and that's what they built in and on top
of all of that if you've been watching
the videos we've seen some big sensor
smartphones before and what's my first
complaint always when i take a close-up
photo with the shallow background
there's often a lot of fringing around
that main subject
and so
that samsung feature from a couple years
ago variable aperture would have been
kind of neat
well it's back so sony has built back in
the changing aperture feature from the
galaxy s9 days so there's a toggle in
the camera ui that can physically close
down the aperture from f 2.0 to f 4.0 so
in broad daylight or in well-lit
conditions with a close-up subject you
can stop down like a real photographer
and actually get more in focus and the
difference is actually noticeable both
in the sharpness of the subject and the
blurriness level of the background
you'll have to see it on top of all that
this phone also has its own dedicated
sony built bionz image processor that
allows for super fast 20 frames per
second shooting with 315 autofocus
points covering 90 of the frame and
it'll shoot 4k video up to 120 frames
per second it's incredible so sounds
like the hardware of this camera is
pretty incredible right
i mean it is it's not a trick question
it really is but take a look at these
two photos side by side
which one would you pick as better
well most people especially side by side
would pick the one on the left that's
the iphone 13 pro up against the sony
well what about this picture same idea
there's clearly a difference between
them and there's a reason that most
people are picking the photo on the left
obviously the brighter photo catches
your eye usually the most easily but
camera enthusiasts will probably also
notice the better dynamic range on the
left too that's because sony doesn't
really do all that much computational
photography nearly as well as some of
the most popular smartphones with the
multi-frame hdr processing so the sony
result is a more natural
less hdr-e possibly more true-to-life
photo technically
but often one that looks a bit more dull
or more flat and then also if you're
thinking wait why doesn't the background
blur look massively different from the
iphone i thought there's a huge one-inch
sensor in there and you'd be right to
think that because we've arrived at the
catch which is that yes this phone does
have a one-inch sensor inside physically
pretty crazy but
this phone doesn't actually use the
entire one-inch sensor from corner to
corner so when i held up the phone next
to the rx100 earlier
yes these two things have the same
sensor but clearly the pocket camera is
a lot thicker there's there's way more
z-axis space to work with for all that
high-quality glass in front of the
sensor great
on a smartphone the optics have to be i
mean you can see it's super super small
it's pushed up much closer to the sensor
and unfortunately they're so close to
this one that the image circle covered
by the lens doesn't actually cover the
whole sensor so you know since lenses
are circles when they let in light that
light travels down the barrel and
projects an image circle onto the back
of the camera and that's picked up by
the rectangular sensor back there so our
photos are all rectangles but that's
because they're cutting the rectangular
image out of the entire circle that's
being projected back there so in this
phone's case the image circle is
actually smaller than the one-inch
sensor so the photos it's spitting out
are a subset of a subset of that silicon
it's actually a 12 megapixel crop of
that whole
20 megapixel one inch sensor in there to
begin with effectively making it a one
over 1.3 inch sensor that's actually
being used
and then
dual aperture like i said it's really
cool it's great and all that to have
with a big sensor but
f2 as the maximum aperture
is actually not as wide as most of the
other highest end smartphone cameras out
today which are around f 1.5 f 1.6
letting in even more light than this
so when you combine these two
realizations that the effective sensor
size is smaller
and that the max aperture is also
smaller it turns out the xperia i is
actually gathering less light and has
less overall bokeh than phones like the
iphone 13 pro or galaxy s21 ultra or
pixel 6. what a
wild quark feature to have that it's got
this crazy huge sensor but it's unable
to use all of it and you know maybe in a
future version they were able to use
more z space or maybe a larger overall
camera cutout on the back i don't know
exactly what fixes this but
yeah that's that's one of the most
interesting things i've seen in a phone
a long time and there's obviously more
to a camera or more to a phone
than just the camera but you know when
it's the xperia i for imaging and when
it's 1800
and when it's got a one-of-a-kind sensor
that's kind of what you're looking at so
yeah this this particular phone is one i
would probably only recommend to people
who obviously have a lot of money to
burn but are really looking for the
manual control offered by the apps that
sony ships with these phones kind of the
same way they did with the xperia one
mark iii still amazing all the manual
control with videos too the focus slider
everything built in ah it's great but
you've got to really know what you're
getting yourself into and this is not a
daily for most people
but that being said i am really glad
this exists just because not like it's
some specialty crazy one-inch sensor
one-of-a-kind thing but really
smartphones cameras are all sort of
leveling up again and that's something i
like to see because it feels like one of
the biggest things that still
differentiates all these really good
phones at the high end so yeah
let's keep getting smartphone cameras
better every year love to see it either
way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]